un moustique la rentrer dans la case 1
histoire stéphanie guérineau
l'illustrateur majorie béal coup de main
en créole réunionnais laurence daleau
avec axel gauvin aux éditions epsilon
jeunesse porte attention zippo le
moustique la rente dans la case
si je l'étais à la ville à agra dalli
l'idée si le mur vrai pas vraiment l'irg
est bien tout le monde l'endroit des
pêches vite manque razali avant l'idée
cole bakkali yavo l'angola
tu as moins nous salit la partie poser à
au même il doit à trouve ali il doit
kraz ali dommage la passe près maux de
tête fort imola pour vols vols
prends étape et en automne crachats liés
à la voile
pareils et l'affronter passe à côté
si paul a pas un valet yahya yahya et à
la pac pape a écrit mais ces mots zipoli
nil est encore en vie hallade
al ahly la pose d'une livre de gaza au
vêtement firme livre un coup sec
côté mouvements les bons bravo ou la
mongolie